hi gabby
hi steve
[Music]
so i'm very happy to have with me today
gabby of go natural english
because very often we talk about
learning languages other than english
although english of course is the
language that is the most widely studied
in the world
and in fact many of my viewers i know
many of you out there that you like to
listen to me speak english you can even
import from youtube study it on link if
you want and
it's just content for learning english
but i wanna because gabby in fact i'll
first i'll let gabby introduce herself
and then i have some questions
perfect well it's a pleasure to be here
thank you so much for having me and i
love your channel i love how you help
people to learn all languages and yes go
natural english is to help people learn
english
specifically although we talk about
language learning in general as well so
go natural english is a youtube channel
and a website and a premium course that
i started
in 2011 so several years ago when i was
teaching english in japan in an american
corporation in japan just after i'd
finished my masters in in tesol and
it came out of my desire to help my
students learn more they were having
some problems learning from old
textbooks and kind of old
teaching methods and i wanted to help
them more with the conversational
english that they want and and and need
for work
and you have quite a large number of
subscribers i believe oh yes almost 2
million almost so if you want to come
over and subscribe and help us get there
that would be please do so we will leave
a link in the description box
and
you may be aware that i like having
these discussions with these language
entrepreneurs who are helping people you
know via the internet to learn languages
in ways that are different from the more
traditional ways of learning languages
so english now
you know
people learning other languages
typically they're attracted by the
culture you know korean drama or
you know they want to travel to south
america or italy or you know japan or
anime but english is more like it's a
need like people need english they have
to have english if they want to go to
school in north america or england or
something or they for their job
so so
what are some of the problems if you
were to try to identify problems not so
much with the language we'll get into
that later but as people learning
english what are the obstacles that they
face
yeah i think because it is seen as such
a necessary task
english learning feels like something
you have to do whether you want to or
not and it loses some of its um
some of its allure it loses some of that
you know you feel like you have to do
something and then you don't want to do
it um it's it's a problem because
you know i i think this comes from
when we were forced to learn english
maybe in high school or college or maybe
now if you want to
advance in your career you feel like you
have to do this and you go to a class
and
they use kind of old teaching methods
where you're expected to be perfect and
listen to lectures and not get to speak
very much and then when you do speak you
make a mistake and your teacher says bad
mistakes are bad and you you're left
feeling like frustrated you know like
this is not fun this is not something i
want to do but i have to do it
it's it's not fun anymore and that's i
think a big problem in english learning
in general maybe language learning maybe
for other languages as well i mean i
remember when i was learning spanish in
college and i felt similar that i
couldn't make a mistake i couldn't try
new vocabulary words to see how they
might work in conversation because my
teacher might say well that's that's not
right and i encourage english learners
and language learners to make more
mistakes because that's how we learn but
to answer your question i think it's a
kind of a challenge or a problem that
we're starting from this mindset of oh
english is something i have to do and
don't really want to and where is our
motivation then our motivation is
lacking in that situation you know it's
a bit like if i think of school children
in in canada who have to learn french
and they don't really need the french to
communicate so if you live in japan
you don't really need the english that
much even though your employer wants you
to have a score on toeic or whatever
so why am i learning this i don't
there's no one around me that speaks
english i don't have to learn it like
how do you overcome that like most
people learning english don't live if we
if we exclude the sort of immigrants in
north america
most most english learners don't need it
on a daily basis and they don't have an
opportunity to use it on a daily basis
they might be in brazil they might be in
you know russia or somewhere
china korea how how do you overcome that
it's it's very frustrating because
you don't need it on a daily basis and
you don't hear it on a daily basis but
when you do need it like in a business
meeting or an interview it's really
important and it's so high pressure um
so how do you overcome that so a lot of
it is
mindset because we've developed kind of
a negative mindset around english that
mistakes are bad and i'll never be good
at english
i can't speak english this kind of
mindset a lot of english learners start
a conversation saying hi my name is
gabby and my english is very poor for
example and you know this is a very
negative way to think about your skills
to think about english and so the number
one step
even though it may seem kind of silly
but the number one step is to break that
mindset and decide i can speak english
i will be a fluent english speaker and
yes i'm deciding right now that this is
my identity i am an english speaker
maybe i don't speak perfect english but
we don't need to tell people that and we
also don't need to focus on that instead
we can think ah every day i'm improving
a little bit and that is how we start
with a positive mindset of course now
after we change our mindset and start
thinking more positively
then we can talk more about language
acquisition but the first step so
important and often overlooked
is your mindset and deciding yes i can
speak english you know and i think
listening comprehension is is extremely
important
obviously and in that regard i should
point out that i watched some of your
videos and you speak very very clearly
and
i try to speak clearly here obviously
not every native speaker speaks clearly
and eventually we have to get used to
understanding people who don't speak so
clearly
but while people are learning it's an
advantage to be able to access
you know the language spoken clearly it
doesn't have to be spoken slowly but it
should be at least spoken clearly so i
think that's a big plus uh at your
channel you do speak very you speak at a
normal speed but you speak very very
clearly i'm glad you said that because a
lot of people ask me in the comments are
you speaking slowly is this normal so
i'm speaking clearly i'm speaking in a
professional way that i might make a
presentation in no i'm not speaking in a
super fast way i might with someone i'm
very close to like when i'm hanging out
with my friends and joking around um but
yeah it is normal so i'm glad you said
that yeah oh that's good uh so
and uh before we go to the sort of
specific difficulties of the english
language and they are many starting with
the spelling
but uh
are there any particular tips okay have
a positive attitude uh believe you can
do it these are things that i say quite
often and i totally agree with it's
amazing how the brain
you know our emotional state can
influence our success but are there
specific tricks or tips that you like to
give your english learners yes so i have
a five-step process the first step is to
decide that you can the mindset and then
the second is to make sure you're
getting a lot of input meaning
you are consuming english you're
listening to english or watching shows
with english maybe you're watching this
interview in english uh for example it
could be a number of different things
but make sure that you have
input and it should be at an appropriate
level so if you're an intermediate
english learner it's fine to start
listening to native speaker content um
after listening okay we want to
copy what we're hearing and use it so
practice and really do this as
fast as soon as you can so not
necessarily
quickly speaking quickly but as soon as
you start listening to more english
start saying what you're hearing out
loud it's called shadowing so you can
select a phrase that you like and start
repeating that to yourself you don't
need to have another person in front of
you to start speaking you can just talk
to yourself so practice okay so we have
the mindset we have the input we have
practice the fourth step is it is
important to get feedback on your
english this could be talking to someone
else and seeing if they understand you
and you know if you see this uh glazed
overlook in their eyes like i have no
idea what you're saying well okay then
you go from there it could be um
you know even talking to something
electronic like siri or a google voice
or something um you know what see if it
understands you in english it could be
working with a teacher or a tutor and
getting feedback and corrections
that is really important to see where
you're making mistakes uh i will mention
also you could record yourself i get
really excited about this this um this
step you know there's a lot of ways to
get feedback listening to yourself on
your recording the fifth step
is
repeat all of the previous steps so it's
important
with your mindset
every day remind yourself i can do this
it's not something you just do once it's
really important to continue and repeat
this whole process
i agree with you too about hearing
yourself because i think a lot of our
mistakes we find them ourselves we in a
way we don't need to have them pointed
out if we listen to ourselves
um we'll see where we make mistakes
every time i make a video in another
language and i watch that video i see my
mistakes not that i will then correct it
unfortunately i'm condemned to make that
same mistake a few more times before i
manage to avoid it okay let's talk a bit
about english what are the the big
problems well you know if people come to
you and say look i'm having trouble with
this aspect of english or that aspect of
english is there sort of a list of the
most common problems people have with
english
yeah i get a lot of the same questions
over and over so
one that's really interesting is about
the th sound in english which
which you know i thought it was uh just
in english but i guess it's in some
other languages but you have two th
sounds that and the
and
a lot of a lot of english learners ask
me about how to make the sound or they
say it's very difficult to make this
sound but it's interesting that this is
a question i get asked a lot because
it's not necessarily
super important to make this sound
perfectly in order to be understood
so
it's kind of a nice thing to have in
your toolbox
to sound more like a native speaker but
it's not the most important thing
another question i get asked a lot is
how can i make longer sentences more
complex sentences
and i guess
we're thinking okay this means i'm more
advanced if i can make long sentences
but it's again not necessarily a good
thing because sometimes when you have
these long
drawn out
run-on sentences
it's not clear at all what you're saying
right
it's kind of funny it's not necessarily
better communication to make a longer
sentence
yeah no that's those are both x and it's
it's because writing is a great way to
start outputting
and it's obviously easier to make
shorter sentences and i think people
tend to overuse the sort of and or
whatever connector and they end up with
a great long sentence and they'd be
better off each little thought stop
starting the sentence stop
it it's better uh from every from every
uh you know point of view
um yeah so that's good so um
yeah english is a little different from
learning these other languages because
it's perceived as more of a necessity
rather than a romantic adventure
uh and you're there to help people so
we're leaving a link in the description
box this discussion too i think we'll
make it available as a lesson that link
or if not people can go to youtube
and with the browser extension we have
you can bring that in as a lesson
in link and certainly gabby speaks very
clearly i like to think i speak clearly
so it could be a good place for people
to practice their listening
comprehension so thank you very much
gabby and congratulations on getting
close to 2 million subscribers
it might take me a while to get there
but that's a great achievement thank you
very much thank you so much steve thank
you
[Music]